what is that where y'all put the camera
closer because I want to know not me
yeah he needs a closet do you have wings
that come out of your costume does it
talk does it talk
[Music]
Kabira knowledge man come on it's more
humid it's not talking
[Applause]
Darrell I'm Darrell in the load Oh God I
love you Justin I love you Jared I love
you I love you
but you were all very beautiful but this
question is for Jeremy so so when is
Kevin coming back
[Applause]
not to put you on his bunk now never
I got are your little piece of heaven
with me at all times that's why I love
you mine
ladies and gentlemen Oscar Chow hey oz
is this I'm just these are pajamas what
exactly no it's a video game called
journey the very beautiful game it has a
wonderful soundtrack you should try it
you could have saved a lot but you could
have saved a lot of time and effort by
dressing up as Kevin Tran just saying I
have three lives prepared and your
spitting image - it would have been
really be awesome in retrospect that
would have been a great idea this is the
first time I've seen it it looks really
good
[Applause]
anyway thanks guys let me say again
[Applause]